it's interesting the other day I went to
I went to this bookstore this is cool
experience I had yesterday there's one
actually left I know right there's this
little independent used bookstore
beautiful is over in Atwater Village and
I walked in and I saw these beautiful
typewriters of these Remington's that
were reconstructed and painted and
beautiful and I was drawn into it and
there was this woman there that was she
was writing on it I was like these are
beautify one but I was checking it out
she goes oh these are my my typewriters
like oh are they on exhibit and she goes
yeah they're on exhibit and she said I'm
actually a poet I'm doing a kind of a
exhibit and I'm like what kind of poet
are you and she goes well I do this
thing where I look into your eyes you
can tell me a word or a theme or
something and tell me something that's
relevant to you and then I'll write a
poem for you and you can just pay me
whatever you think it's worth I was like
that's amazing I have to do this yeah it
was very cool so there was this phrase
that was going through my head earlier
in the day of the outrunning ghosts it's
just an interesting idea and so I
mentioned that and she she looked at me
for a little bit and I could see the
wheels turning and there's this kind of
unique connection and then she turns
around it's a small slip of paper into
the the Remington and she starts typing
and she starts out with the first
outrunning ghosts of love she wrote and
then she started writing this poem it
just flowed out of her and it like she
almost ran out of space and she says
that rarely happens because something
connected and I just worked she pulled
it out and she said can I read it to you
I was like yes of course it's even
better so she read it to me and I was
surprised that genuinely moved me and
I'm I love poetry most poetry's awful
and so I'm a little skeptical when it
comes to poetry but I wanted to hear it
and she came from such an emotionally
open place when she wrote about so she
started writing
thing that genuinely moved me and you
know my eyes teared up and she realized
then she got emotional from it as well
and what was most amazing was that she
was actually tapping into something that
was deeply relevant to me personally and
I think that right there is the core of
great writing which is that she opened
herself up emotionally and she delved
into her own subconscious in a way that
she was able to extract this metaphors
that resonated with me in a very very
deep way we don't know each other at all
her name is Jacqueline Susskind and I
just remember because it she assigned it
and put her name at the bottom of the
poem and it was this beautiful
experience where just by engaging the
metaphors that were relevant to her she
spoke to something that I needed to
learn an experience and that to me is at
the core of what what it means to be a
writer it's at the core what I mean to
be an artist to engage those metaphors
and so what we're trying to do as
writers screenwriters novelists
storytellers short stories whatever
we're trying to delve into that
meaningful place that vulnerable place
and in some way diagnose or identify or
even just express some conflict through
the metaphors we're engaging and that's
where we find the meaning the anatomy of
chaos so do you think she's like an
empathic poet is that definitely she was
showing pure empathy um I don't like I'm
skeptical when it comes to you know
supernatural things and things like that
but um whatever whatever metaphor she
was dealing with or that she was drawing
on spoke directly to me in a really
beautiful way and and I think great
writers can do that I think very you
know and when I say great writers I mean
I think everybody should be writing it
makes us all better psyche Vonnegut says
go write a poem it'll make you a better
person
but great writers are able to tap into
that that subconscious in such a way
that they'll speak to a human experience
that connects to all of us interesting
you said ghosts cuz I just finished
every love story is a ghost story
I thinking about David Foster Wallace oh
so it's about his his life I couldn't
read the end that breaks my heart it's
too sad and I started to get angry in
sometimes because he was so talented
yeah and and I felt like it was it was
such a waste and I was very upset and I
couldn't read the end but I read the
beginning in the middle and it's just an
interesting concept of ghosts as well
because because in some sense is that
all we're seeking is is this like just
how she wrote this poem just like this
empathic experience through what we what
we watched what we read are we looking
for what we're watching to basically
tell us about ourselves yeah and so I
was just wondering and you brought up
the ghosts so that was just interesting
because I had just finished that but
yeah yeah that's beautiful
yeah David Foster Wallace yeah
you